hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
[Music]
Monday
July 24th
2023 what's going on how why yeah
how's it going can you hear the
frustration in my voice already can you
hear it Oh my Jesus Lord and savior
Jesus aged Christ on a [__] Christmas
tree whatever the hell they used to say
back in the day
I'm I'm wiped out
uh my daughter informed me late last
night she said Dad
that's how she first starts to ask me
she goes dad and then if I say no it
becomes dad
so she goes dad
I want to have a daddy daughter day
tomorrow
will you do that with me and I said
absolutely that sounds fantastic so we
planned out this whole day
and uh
it's now like 7 20 at night
and I'm not gonna say she's bouncing off
the walls but I was ready to go to sleep
for the night about two hours ago
can't believe how wiped out I am we went
we went to an arcade
and we then we did some you know it was
great shooting zombies and driving cars
and all of that having a great time
um played some miniature golf
then I took her out for an ice cream
then she said she wanted to go to a toy
store and I'm looking up Toys R Us so
they don't exist anymore and I know Toys
R Us took over child world
so I thought there was still one Toys R
Us left in LA but they all said
permanently closed
so she's like well let's go to Target
I'm like I don't want to go to Target
Target doesn't have good toys
she was like Dad don't say that I'm like
I'm telling you it's it's mostly crap so
we go in there
right
you know there's some sort of domestic
dispute going out in front of the plate
you know it's a Superstore
you're going to run into everybody
everybody goes into a Superstore it's
like a [__] black hole of consumerism
it just it draws everybody in there's
there's the [__] boxes there's [__]
expensive cars there's homeless people
there's [__] moms right there's just
everybody's there
this people shooting up there's people
on [__] pot cookies there's people
that just work there right and there's
dads with their kids showing up to try
to find something at those seven aisles
of [__] that they have right
they got a couple decent things
a couple of Tonka trucks
sports section they got some basketballs
footballs bats and [__]
but even then I would go to Dick's right
I feel like I'm doing a commercial right
now for dicks but anyway
we go in there right and they don't have
anything
then we go over to the video game
section it's like I'm not signing off on
any of this [__] because I don't know
what any of this stuff is so then we go
back
she's kind of standing there and I look
up and I see these stupid things these
this kid Ryan
's World he's got these these [__]
eggs and I bought them before these
plastic eggs and inside of them are all
these toys and every one of them is just
this little plastic piece of [__] the
[__] egg never comes back together
again one of them I swear to God I don't
know if it had like supposed to have
like lava it was a bunch of colored sand
it got all over the house you can never
get the egg back together they play with
it like that day and the next day and
then you just got this it's just a bunch
of plastic [__]
someday it's going to get thrown out
it's going to end up in the ocean and
just float around bothering porpoises
for the next [__] 800 to a thousand
years if we even have that much time
left on a livable planet right so
I survived that
we get out and I forgot that I told her
we'd go swimming afterwards I was kind
of hoping she'd forget that but that was
the best part well the the miniature
golf and the uh
and the arcade was fun
and then the swimming was great because
we've been in the pool almost every day
it's my favorite thing to do is go
swimming with my kids plus watch them
get better at it knowing that they're
all right
and they've been taking swimming lessons
from a great teacher once a week and
then I just swim with them the whole
week
and uh
so now you know they can both swim which
is huge
which is huge that's bigger than riding
a bike you know
[Laughter]
the bike you bounce on the ground no
biggie you can still breathe you fall
into a [__] pool you know so
um
ended up doing that but Jesus Christ
takes a lot out of you you know what I
saw when I was there they had batting
cages too
at this place
and um
I don't think I've been in a batting
cage I can't even remember I was
thinking like I didn't have to set that
to about 35 miles an hour
to get around and catch up with
something but I wanted to get in there
so bad
take a couple of rips
see what the [__] happened see if I
still got a little bit of freckled power
in me
you know
you walk by the cage you're still
fantasizing some Scout's going to see
you in a batting cage next to a
miniature golf course
you know
you know I can believe this is a 55 year
old rookie just signed with the
Milwaukee Brewers
um
yeah anyway so that was kind of uh
that was my day had a big week I uh
I told you guys on I don't know if
they're telling you Thursday no I
finally soloed up to Santa Barbara
I did that
and then the next two days later I went
up and I soloed up to Santa Ynez
and uh
uh I just never flown around up there
it's a really uh
just a fun place to be it's not a lot of
people's weekdays there wasn't a lot of
people up there
and
um
really beautiful
really peaceful the second day I went up
there
uh
you know went up to Santa Ynez I just I
just flew around Santa Barbara's
airspace
uh so one of these days I'm gonna I'm
gonna figure out how to fly all the way
up to pass a Robles
that's as far as I want to go I think
you know at that point
you get you know
you [__] ass is killing you by the
time you get back
I flew a uh what was it 2.2 that's like
enough because I sort of landed I
stretched a little bit I went in and I
got a water
and then I took off again
and uh
on the way back as I was going through
like Simi Valley
I feel like I've been on a bicycle too
long I was like I just want to land this
thing you know what's funny was this guy
came in and for whatever reason
he landed this a star
facing the opposite way
you know
then
The Way We Were Landing so all the other
helicopts were pointed the other way and
the only little uh Landing Pad area was
the one right next to his so our Tails
were both
you know I would have had so much more
space If he if he had landed the other
way I don't know why he landed that way
um
especially in a star because I heard
they're really squirrely
and to be landing with the with the
Tailwind I don't know why you would do
that but he did whatever
um
so that made that fun when I came back
he was still there
so I didn't have the nice wide turn to
line it up with the pad that it kind of
like tuck it in and then come forward
and set it down and I wasn't happy the
way I landed and I lifted it up set it
back down again which I usually once I
set it on the pad I'm like all right
well you know I did kill myself let's
leave it at that and this time I was
like no lift it up and put it where you
wanted to put it
and I was able to do that and uh pretty
proud of myself so if I can get a couple
more hours in here at the end of the
month I'm trying to get like 10 hours in
a month which I have not done once
this year I've I've haven't flown much
at all this year because I've just been
you know busy on the road and and
whatever
doing [__] and then being a dad so
um but these longer flights that I now
know how to do if I get a day where I
can go like you know knock out a couple
hours I feel like I can stay uh pretty
proficient or whatever but you guys
don't want to hear all of that [__] do
you
I mean what else am I going to do right
now it's the dog days of summer
I have so many friends of mine that are
sports fans just going like dude this is
the worst part of the year I don't know
what to do it's like [__] they had
Wimbledon they just had Wimbledon
you got baseball uh kid a little
baseball well it's not fast it's too
slow for you
is that what it is you have to think
I hate people who whine about [__]
baseball I've done it too but it's just
like it's a great [__] game quit your
[__] whining
you know
get yourself a lawn chair and a little
AM FM transistor radio
you know a little picture of [__]
Arnold Palmer and just sit there and
listen to the Ball Game
I get it
you know it's not the NBA every five
seconds everybody clap their hands you
dick
the [__] slap on your hand off your
[__] forehead
the NBA I swear to God the NBA is for
[__] morons not the game not the
people that play it not the strategy
none of that [__] but as as a Fan
Experience
the level of dumb that they think that
you are
that God forbid a half a second goes by
we have to keep these people entertained
the entire [__] time they they treat
everybody there like like a [__]
toddler
on on a [__] transcontinental flight
jumping around they do everything but
wiggle [__] you know dangle keys in
front of your face God for [__] bid
you sit there for two seconds and
contemplate what the [__] you just
watched and try to figure out what's
going on the court
how can I do that when a hundred
scantily clad [__] [__]
wearing less clothes than what
prostitutes were when I was a kid come
running out and start tumbling spinning
plates or whatever the [__] is happening
all right
all right God damn it try to listen to
my Travis Trick
I have to tell you something that's my
favorite thing to yell in a Southern
accent Travis Tritt
I'm going down
but I care because these liberal [__]
[__] got a goddamn parade
I want to start you know because my my
son has started cursing because of me so
I gotta watch what I say
um
I gotta watch what I say I'm gonna just
start doing like
I'm just gonna say
like country singers
like there's something really oh Travis
Trent right
Charlie Daniels
I gotta get because it's gonna put me in
a stupid mood I'll stop cursing
Alpha there's no there's no country
singer with an F is it
ah
instead of saying for [__] sakes
ah Waylon Jennings
Travis Tritt's the only one that just
[__] brings a smile to my face and
also I feel the anger leave my body
like when I say [__] or [__]
it's one of my favorite names in show
business
Travis Tritt
you know what I mean
like how do you not say that name and
not have a [__] smile on your face
Travis Tritt it's [__] amazing it's
like my kids they get in the water you
get in water there's buoyancy you're
immediately smiling smiling right maybe
that's what it is is there is it
possible
for a name to be buoyant
what am I even talking about right now I
don't know
I have no idea you know what it is is
I'm actually stressing right now because
I know it's it's like 7 30 and my son's
gonna start acting up
and uh
you know we're working on his his temper
tantrums
like all kids have at his age so we're
just like ignoring it and uh
oh man he had one the other night I
swear to God
he was yelling so much I thought my
neighbors were gonna
you know
come knocking on the door or something
and uh
I just waited it out 20 minutes
he's stubborn you know and he finally
just tuckered himself out
and then when he was quiet I went over
and I put the toothpaste on the
toothbrush I handed it to him and then
he was all quiet going like
okay brush teeth brush teeth
I didn't say anything
and then he gets in bed he's like Dada
read story that every story I go I just
nodded and I grabbed the book
I read him good night good night
construction site or maybe
farming strong all year long one of
those ones right
and then he goes all right night data
and I gave him a nice hug and a kiss I
said all right good night buddy and he
just went right to sleep he had warned
himself the only thing I've ever seen
wear him out the only thing they could
wear him out is him
unbelievable
it's like you know they're like they're
a [__] new car
everything works everything's brand new
everything does what it's supposed to do
just responds
I was watching what the hell was I
watching
oh because I've been doing like a lot of
stretching of course I haven't been
doing the last week I got to get back
into it
um
so I've been watching a bunch of like
you know videos because my masseuse
passed away
you know
um
and she was the best so I I was uh
you know Diana Linden Rest In Peace So
I'm so worried my sciatic issues are
going to come back that I've just been
doing all of this stretching and making
sure you know I got the foam roller and
all of that type of stuff so I on
Instagram
there's all these like
it's sort of like yoga but like they
show like
I don't know how to explain it it's not
like yoga it's more like flowing
stretching and stuff like that is stuff
good for your hips his stuff good for
your back and all that type of stuff so
because I did that now my algorithm it's
all like these workout videos
so it's all these guys like lifting
doing like this crazy kettlebell [__]
and they every one of those ones when I
watch the video the entire time I'm
watching it I'm just going ow ow
but they're young and their shoulders
are still good their knees are still
good
um if you're young
and you're lifting weights and all of
that just please
get a personal trainer and and work on
your form
so you don't you don't accidentally wear
out joints and [__] because uh
becomes a [__] but I will say
this I I've dropped a bunch of weight
this uh
this month
oh [__]
coveted [__] belly is going down
and not Billy fat cakes anymore
all right I'm sort of like an acceptable
I have an acceptable punch
right now but I'm Gonna Keep like I'm
gonna keep going because uh I I just I'm
not doing this anymore it's so stupid I
walked around this wait for three
[__] years and all I had to do was
just
you know
three weeks just three weeks get on it
turn the whole [__] ship around and
be Billy slim cakes the green shirt diet
the green shirt [__] diet
is on the board here so
um
here's something that I've had to deal
with a lot in my life is narcissists
and um
it's kind of crazy every time I feel
like I got the last narcissist out of my
life
another one
like pops up
and I'm just so fascinated like how they
don't know what causes it
like they don't know if you're born with
it
and then they're like is it over a tent
could be over attention as a child under
attention as a child I don't know what
it is I I feel like
I feel like you get too much attention I
don't think you become a narcissist I
think you just become an arrogant ass
I think it could come if I had a guess
with no s you know psychology degree
whatsoever no no training no nothing
I think it comes from neglect and
feeling absolutely worthless and then
the only way that you can survive is in
your head you build yourself into being
like this God
to try to that's the only way you can
level yourself out
narcissistic personality disorder is a
mental health condition in which people
have an unreasonably high sense of their
own importance
they need and seek too much attention
and want people to admire them
well Jesus Christ I'm I'm All That
sentence right there people with this
disorder may lack the ability to
understand or care about the the
feelings of others all right I don't
have that this is like a Serial do you
ever look like the [__]
the uh
what do they call it the uh
the top five traits of a serial killer
and you got like three of them
it's like I came so close
all of those rest areas in my stand-up
career that I just drove by if I was
just one more thing I would have gone in
there
28 day workout challenge for seniors
this is for seniors and it starts ages
40 to 45 45 to 50 50 to 55 that kind of
that guy looks like Santa Claus he's
shredded
he's got Dwayne Johnson's torso with
Santa Claus with a Santa Claus [__]
beard that's 50 to 55 and 55 plus
oh Jesus you're gonna get that shredded
that's HGH and steroids
um
anyway here's the symptoms have an
unreasonably High uh sense of
self-importunity to that one feel that
they deserve Privileges and special
treatment expect to be recognized as
Superior even without achievements this
sounds like half the women I dated make
achievements and talents seem bigger
than they are be preoccupied with
fantasies about success power Brilliance
beauty beauty or the Perfect Mate
uh I definitely had I was preoccupied
with fantasies about success
believe they are superior to others who
can only spend
time no I have a crushing need to be
liked uh be critical or look down on
people they feel are not important all
of this type of [__] all right let's
look up serial killers
I got a lot with them I don't have a lot
with narcissists all right
cereal
killer top traits
top [__] traits Travis Tritt
um the most
most serial killer traits are
grandiosity
narcissism superficial charm
manipulation
addictive personality bing bing bing
bing bing I got that lust for power
sensation seeking
is that porn addiction well give me that
that's two
the McDonald Triad
well I don't like I don't like that list
I thought I thought I had more than that
why would I want to have more than that
really bill just for comedy sake
did you see that [__] BTK killer they
caught this other serial killer and he
was basically like you know
that guy's a carbon copy of me he
basically a serial killer said about
another serial killer he's ripping me
off man
hahaha
he's the Greta Van Fleet a [__]
a [__] serial killers man he's just
doing Zeppelin uh 11 11 common signs of
a serial killer the most common traits
are a lack of empathy lack of remorse
impulsivity
grandiosity narcissism superficial charm
manipulation addictive personality
lesser power sensation seeking what is
the [__] McDonald Triad
well we got to see this now
you know what's hilarious is I'm
scrolling down there's video of Jeffrey
Dahmer
and
then there's a picture of George Clooney
for the completely different article
like George Clooney's a super serial
killer
grandiosity
tell me the BTK killer is not Mr White
for Breaking Bad
uh
if he actually shaved his whole head
all right hang on a second
where are we going
the McDonald Triad and animal cruelty oh
boy
experts believe that the McDonald's
trying
post three specific specific behaviors
in children which suggest a person may
become violent as an adult bedwetting
Fire Starting and childhood abuse
towards animals
who's the McDonald guy
the McDonald let's find McDonald Triad
history
who who are you who came up
with the McDonald's uh
how do you spell Donald Triad
was it Michael McDonald there's all the
five [__] things that make you a
killer
[Music]
I know people love him but he doesn't he
also kind of sound like a Tesla backing
up
all right
the McDonald Triad was developed in 1961
by John McDonald
he always had to name it after yourself
to make sure you got credit that was me
the Triad of okay all right so John
McDonald
John McDonald know about serial killers
e-i-e-i-o and he came up with three
[__] things and he named it after
himself
um all right I thought I had more
well then what the [__] am I
the top what should I you guys tell me
what I should Google the top five
traits
of a dumb bald [__] oh somebody used an
expression wrong
he's not the smartest he's not the
smartest tool in the shed
[Music]
I love that one because it's just
[__] on somebody for being dumb as
you're not smart enough to say it
correctly fantastic did I mention I have
a new show added
Reno Nevada October 28th at the Reno
Events Center pre-sale is Wednesday at
10 A.M local time with code Burr on sale
to the public Friday
two reads
all right wait
new show added Reno Nevada October 28th
at the Reno Events Center pre-sales
Wednesday at 10 A.M code Burr on sale
Friday I love Reno
Godfather the two baby
um oh what cool it is everybody game
time game time Travis
Travis Trey you get your [__] ass in
here right now
all right game time
um
buying tickets to your favorite event
shouldn't be stressful
uh game time it's the fast and easy way
to buy tickets for all sports music
comedy and theater near you with killer
deals on last minute tickets and their
best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you'll have
game time is the the best place for last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the
events it's the fastest growing ticket
app in the country for a reason get
images of your seat before you buy
seeing exactly what to expect when you
arrive
well not really what if you have some
drunk sitting behind you do they [__]
they paint that guy in belching in your
ear buy tickets in a matter of seconds
two Taps and you're set tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email I love that
all right cutting out the middleman of
[__] that makes old dads like me [__]
things up snag the ticket without stress
the stress with Game Time download the
game time app create an account and use
the code Burr b u r r for twenty dollars
off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
Burr for twenty dollars off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed
all right Bill Good emails
all right retirement tour
we'll be talking about Elton John
you know I'm a dreamer no that's that's
[__] Motley Crew
who's Elton John
what's a good Elton John Daniel my
brother you are older than me do you
still feel the pain
I still want to hear that third verse
that was anti-warf
and he was like do I make a statement
about war
or do I am I able to buy another [__]
bedazzled Donald Duck suit
and he chose himself uh retirement tour
everybody dear Bill A co-worker of mine
told me that he heard your honor on a
radio interview
say that this was your last tour
I won't be able to see this time around
in my hometown but is this your last
tour I may have to fly somewhere to see
you can you give me some clarity no it's
not my last tour
I don't know why this person thought I
said that maybe I alluded to uh
you know I don't know
being tired on the road
listening to Travis
um
I always threatened to do [__] like that
but then I'm just like well what the
[__] would I do oh my God I know what I
would do I'd become 450 pounds
that's what I would do
I'd go to the movies
you know what I would do I would putts
around town
even though I live in this giant [__]
City I really live I like just living in
a couple of blocks
you know
if I get across like two major streets
I'm just like you know what I I don't
want to do that
that's what I think we need to do people
we all everybody needs to live a smaller
[__] life and you know where it
should start at the airport
all right here's my question
to all the people at the airport where
the [__] are you going
I've never seen so many goddamn families
traveling all all the whole [__] year
where the [__] are you going
stop spoiling your kids
my wife said that the other day she goes
you're going to be alone with our son
what are you going to do with them
I'm like nothing we're staying home we
got a backyard we got a bunch of [__]
toys
How come every day has to be some you
know Chuck E cheese and let's let's go
to the [__] trampoline place they
didn't have any of that [__] look at the
[__] parents like go outside
pick up a stick and imagine it's
something
all right I have coffee to drink
cigarettes to smoke
I'm making Jello get outside
and then you'd be excited she's making
Jello oh I hope she puts a walnut in the
middle of it
that was the worst [__] ever Jello was
just [__] disgusting it didn't even
know it was made of sugar it didn't even
taste it it just was [__]
I don't know what it was
like if you like McDonald's they're
always talking about it yeah that pink
slime
at least the pink slime is [__]
delicious
oh god there was this [__] woman
across the street she had this recipe my
mother made it
like in jello they would put like grapes
in nuts and all of this stuff and then
put like whipped cream on top of it it
was just a [__] abomination
it was literally like a slaughterhouse
like whatever was left on the floor you
just threw it into a hot dog this was
like the the I don't know what the
dessert version of it
but anyway
um
no I am not
I am not anywhere near retiring
but I am gonna I am working around my
family though
like I'm not just [__] gonna be out
there
you know Road dogging the way I used to
or whatever and then going right to an
acting gig and then [__] taping a
special and then writing a new hour and
[__] doing I'm not doing that not
doing that [__] anymore so and whatever
the prices I have to pay I don't give a
[__] because
I would rather do what I did today
um
you know with my kids and everything I
had just had a great time
you know
that's what sucks that I'm spending so
much time with my kids and I still have
to listen to people going make sure you
take it in
make are you taking it in are you yes I
am I'm here
I I have I have the disposable income
and the time to be around and I'm
enjoying it okay thank you for your
[__] warning
you know just just make sure you enjoy
just take take lots of pictures take I'm
doing that I'm taking video yes you told
me I get it long videos don't take quick
ones you wish you took longer ones I got
it I got it I've taken in all the
information thank you thank you
I'm actually gonna miss out on their
childhood listening to people warning
you know finishing like warning me
just make sure you take it all in
by the way when the [__] did that happen
where everybody just has this this
[__]
you know
this need
to give out like
life advice like unsolicited
you're gonna give me some pointers on
how to live life
give me some pointers on how to be a dad
next time somebody says that make sure
you take it all in I want to be like oh
yeah
how did your kids turn out
like what where's your credentials I
don't see any [__] diploma on the
wall who the [__] are you
oh you got kids I have kids too
fantastic you have a car I have a car
too I'm not gonna tell you how to
maintain it I'm not a mechanic
that's the funniest thing about being a
[__] parent is anybody can do it
you know
anybody can become a [__] parent you
know unless you got some medical issues
right
unless God didn't want you to [__]
reproduce but even then you can go
around it
you know what I mean
you can sign some woman to a [__]
nine-month contract
to be in your league before you send it
back down to the miners
um
yeah anybody can [__] do it so like
they're acting like they're like taking
you under their wing
you know I didn't I'm not looking for a
mentor
are you taking it in
you know life goes by so fast
oh yeah have you savored every second of
it
so you're gonna waste this part of your
life talking to me about how fast it
goes by you're actually wasting both I
everybody knows it goes by fast
I'm 55 [__] years old do you think
this is the first [__] time and do
you think I haven't noticed
I don't even know who the [__] I'm
talking to right now
um
all over [__] Instagram it's my
favorite thing
he's watching these [__] people who
you don't recognize who never say what
they've achieved telling you how to
achieve
that whole stupid rise and grind
all of that dumb [__] you don't need to
do that okay you can enjoy your life and
be successful and what you think is
Success oh now I'm doing it
I'm just trying to like I'm giving you
advice on how not to listen to other
people's advice
contagious now I need to shut the [__]
up guys just make sure when you're on
Instagram and that you take it all in
because it go four hours of your life
that you're never gonna get back goes by
so fast watching 28 second videos
um
all right
what else do we got here AI
Allen Iverson
that's the only a Iowa I want to know
about hey Bill I haven't heard you talk
about AI That's because it's terrifying
and then I also find it [__]
hilarious
the I I am sad
for the regular working class person
poor person regular [__] gay punches
pants on one time he listens to Travis
Tritt
on his [__] seat eight players still
he's got that all the original one that
was in his old Cutlass got a four CD
changer in the [__] trunk
Tears for Fears is back they never went
away in his car
um
I feel bad for what it's gonna do
for regular people but then there's a
joy that I have
that it's literally going to just
destroy the people that are gonna
unleash it on us it's it's gonna be
like Frankenstein
it's going to turn around and it's going
to literally
you know bite the hand that's made it or
whatever bite the hand that feeds I'm
[__] up I'm giving advice on [__]
up expressions
um
I think the combination of AI in
corporate greed
and their insatiable desire
to make more money every quarter when
you combine the two of those [__]
things
everything from their [__] wing tips
down is going to be Expendable including
the planet
and then eventually when all of that
stuff has been expended it's going to
turn around and it's going to eat them
so
I don't know
I just found out this week that that
when extras work on movies
these corporate [__] scan their face
and then own their face make them sign
something they own their face and then
they can use them as extras and
background and crowd scenes
and on all Medias
yet to be invented and all that for the
rest of [__] time I mean it's just
straight up [__] evil
just the level of [__] greed
I'm telling you in another life I I want
to go the corporate route I just want to
hear those conversations how they just
sit in there and they try and figure out
how to make more and more money and they
just don't give a [__]
who they're hurting
crazy anyway I've heard you talked much
about AI well there you go that's my
opinions on it considering it has
progressed faster than any other
technology it's probably worth noting
noting that your kids will use AR
regularly in their life I don't doubt
that instead of going right to the
doctors they'll be able to get
information as accurate as a doctor as
well as faster and cheaper
they will be as not as non-doctors
they'll be able to get information and
then how are they supposed to process it
as non-doctors getting legal help will
be cheaper as well oh and what else is
it is there going to be the paperless
office
this is every technology that comes out
is supposed to make your life [__]
easier simpler and you're supposed to
work Less hours and it's just never
happening
uh someone victimized by this system
will be able to research what laws they
have to protect them
yeah yeah they're they're doing away
with all laws to protect any individuals
the fact that that [__] [__] that
they put on organic fruit now that wax
they don't even have to say what's in it
they go it's 30 this 70 other stuff that
we're not telling you you didn't used to
be able to do that you used to have to
at least lie
come up with some ingredients they're
like yeah we're not doing that anymore
anyways the big battle is who will
control the information put into the AI
systems
[Music]
rubbing chin I wonder who that will be
Joe's six-pack I don't think so
what is what do you mean the big battle
it's gonna be the same [__] [__]
that have always always been sending the
information into your head the people
that are [__] running [__] and
positions of power they're going to be
the ones that decide what information
you get and they're going to decide how
you're supposed to to uh
process the information if you decide to
process it in a different way you'll be
labeled a Communists or An Enemy of the
State at least in this country I imagine
in Russia you're labeled a capitalist
um
or woke whatever the [__] word is now
um or you'll be you'll be called a
Trumper
yeah just so it doesn't seem like only
people on the right are labeling people
the left probably does more labels than
a right all right the big battle is
who's going to control Bubba is there
anything you'd like to have ai assist
you with in your day-to-day life uh yes
dismantling the corporate structure
and
um racist hate groups I I would start
there
everything else with them I'm pretty
cool with
um
I feel like that was like really like
sent by some AI Corporation man look at
all the great things it's going to do
hey Bill in your life is there anything
you would like to have it assist you
with
it's gonna be a great technology for
everybody you know it all depends though
you know the fly in the ointment is how
it's applied and who has control of it
how many [__] times you heard that
uh
uh all right weight loss medications for
kids
bill was just reading through the news
uh to find an article
for my current events class and found
out that childhood obesity is so bad
that they're considering early intensive
treatment like weight loss medication
what
childhood obesity is not the [__]
problem it's our food supply and lack of
information to the average person so
what you have is somebody who's probably
already obese has a kid and then they
just eat the way their parents do
so instead of treating the cause they're
going to treat the symptom which is
obesity oh my God that's devastating
I feel so bad for those kids my
assignment is to respond to this article
with editorial questions the first one
comes to mind is why are they so fat and
why aren't people asking why they're so
fat
exactly if you want to get to the root
of the problem my only firsthand
experience with kids is my little cousin
and he and all his friends are kind of
fat I'm only 24. even for me when I was
a kid we had to get on a bike or walk to
see our friends
and from what my mom tells me he's just
playing games with them online all day
yeah he already has a [__] desk job
um
all right let me click on this
click on this link here
open link
childhood obesity rates
continue to rise in the U.S affecting
nearly one in five kids in adolescents
so I'm on Twitter Hey is the Twitter guy
going to fight the Facebook guy is that
actually going to happen
and then does the winner fight that
other guy
who's who's fighting the retired
Fighters I think that that's what should
happen
like they have to they have to battle
each other
to be ranked number to get a title shot
at Jake Paul
that would be [__] fantastic first of
all
I would I I'm rooting for the Facebook
guy
you know what I mean
because the Facebook guy he's a [__]
nerd and he's he's still like is acting
like a nerd where I feel like the the
Twitter guy
thinks he's cool now
you know what I mean
he's got the hair plugs he got the
laminated face you know
he's walking around
these [__] lion's mane of jet black
dyed hairy you know he he needs to be
taken I always you know
I feel like he's the guy at the weigh-in
that would do some douchey [__] you know
um anyway childhood obesity rates
continue to rise in the U.S affecting
nearly one in five kids and adolescents
to combat it experts are calling for an
early and intensive treatment for some
kids that may include weight loss
medications oh my God
what to know about weight loss drugs for
teens
Jesus [__] Christ their metabolism is
never going to be higher
just start feeding them healthy food and
tell them to go for a [__] walk
all right Taxidermy and girlfriend's dad
uh Bill my new girlfriend's dad is a
taxidermist
how the [__] does he make a living
don't those people that throw paint on
you they don't come by and throw like
[__] right as he's finishing putting
some eyeballs in a yak they don't come
by and throw a bucket of paint on it
murdered murderers murder man and then
run away whatever the [__] they say Bill
my new girlfriend's dad is a taxidermist
was your old girlfriend's dad a [__]
blacksmith like what
do you live in a commune
my mom doesn't like my girlfriend she
said her forearms are too small and
can't churn butter what do I do all
right this would be fine but he's also a
bit weird yeah I think they're all weird
guys who run funeral pars parlors
taxidermists
they're all weird but I think they
scratched that serial killer itch
they're around it enough the strange
part is that she thinks
he's normal even though she seems normal
and she should think he's strange
example he only eats canned fruit and
never washes his hair oh dude get the
[__] that is coming over your house
every Thanksgiving [__] you I don't give
a [__] what you think about this girl
get that get that whole family tree
that that can take a [__] walk right
there
on top of that he won't eat in a
restaurant he thinks that people
he thinks people that do are the ones
who are weirdos I asked her why hoping
there was some ridiculous reason that I
could use as a placeholder for why
someone would think like that it's
sanitary concerns would be a good reason
for me but nope he doesn't have one
it has me questioning how serious this
relationship could ever get if I have to
have this guy in my life the whole time
am I nuts for thinking this not only are
you not nuts you you [__] you're
you're you're seeing the future
all right part of marrying somebody is
you marry into their family and those
are the [__] people
that are going to be coming over
all right so a [__] weirdo
taxidermist with his smelly ass [__]
hair eating goddamn prunes out of a can
I mean
how soon before he stops cutting his
hair and lets his nails grow like Howard
Hughes
um
I don't know dude I just feel like one
if you married his daughter one day you
know you'd wake up early in the morning
and you'd walk you know
get yourself pull yourself a little
glass of orange juice and as you're
drinking it you know scratching your
lower back listening to Travis Tritt
right you're gonna look out your [__]
window
and just see him standing out there
and it's going to send a jolt
of electricity through your [__]
heart and then he's going to look at you
and then turn and slowly walk away
and then you're going to go upstairs and
be like
honey honey your dad was outside
standing in the yard
and should just be like oh yeah you know
that's just Dad
he does that sometimes
and then you're gonna be like that
doesn't weird you out and he said oh
you're being silly you're being silly
and then later on that night you
brushing teeth and you'll see like I
don't know
next year what beauty [__] they have
you see like a knife in there
be like is that a knife oh yeah yeah it
is
but why is that there I've never seen
that night before
oh I just found it I just I used it I
was I bought a new blouse and I was
cutting a tag off of it
it's just why why what's wrong with you
what do you think I'm gonna kill you
you're doing the right thing
you just gotta [__]
you got to walk away from this
because you know something at no point
did you say like this girl really
has something you can't put your finger
on it I'm not feeling love here
I just feel like this is somebody that
you can get along with that will [__]
you
all right that's not love okay and if
you don't have love
what like even if you just have a
[__]
spend a summer
knowing that any second some guy attacks
a dermist with unwashed hair
with a can of [__] peaches and a
little Fork is going to come walking in
oh my god get the [__] out of that
um
all right anyways congratulations to Max
for stopping I got to watch that race I
was psyched when Lewis Hamilton got the
poll Max got the last five in a row and
I was thinking all right the second half
of the seasons here Mercedes is Gonna
Come on maybe maybe that but maybe
that'll still happen I haven't looked at
the standings in Forever speaking of
which how about those [__] Baltimore
Orioles in first [__] place
the wheels falling off down in Tampa
they're slumping did they Peak too early
which makes no sense like were they
supposed to try and lose games
um
that's another one that makes no sense
did they Peak too early now you try to
win every [__] night I'm sorry we
were winning
we're not trying any less it's a stupid
question asked by fat Sports writers
that were not picked in gym class
the same thing with if four games are in
your building and three games are in
their building if they win game one they
didn't just take away home court
advantage you're still going to have
more home games in your fun even at that
point
you still got [__] three and you're
building three and there's like the math
just doesn't work it's some dumb [__]
made up by people at ESPN I'm blaming
them
um anyway the Baltimore Orioles
the last time I can remember them being
in first [__] place this late in the
season was 1983 and they won it all
with Rick Dempsey
Eddie Murray and Doug desensei
I think Earl Weaver was gone by then
um anyway I think it's [__] great
are the Braves still killing it I love
baseball
I really do and I don't mind that it's a
slow game like they got the pitch count
now the game flies by
it's fantastic
um football fans quit your [__]
whining
when can I start my fantasy football
league
um
I mean people in fantasy football you
get they're right up there they're right
up there with those people
that go to Comic-Con no I mean it's the
same [__] oh my God wait there was a
comedian did a [__] bit about that
that was fantastic let me let me uh let
me get back in my Lane here
um but there is there's something just
[__] pathetic and sad no
fantasy football league
I don't understand I mean just like get
out of the Loveless marriage
you know the only thing I do like about
it is is it's a way to note like almost
everybody in the league
because they just don't make football
cards the way they used to they won't
give you all of them
Bill are you gonna [__] about the same
stuff and maybe I am
maybe I am
um
all right you know what I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna lie to you I feel like so
blessed that I had such a wonderful day
today with my daughter and um
I spent like the last couple days with
my son
and uh you know so all you parents out
there I don't need you to tell me how
special these days are I don't need you
to tell me that they're going to go by
quick I don't need you to tell you
someday you're going to wish that I
realize that
I realize that okay just let me enjoy
this [__] time and stop being some
[__] you know parental ghoul over in
the corner going Sunday
you know I'm not gonna miss it all right
I'm [__] here and I'm enjoying it but
I'm not gonna be literally sitting there
staring at them
they gotta [__] you know have some
time to themselves all right Jesus
[__] Christ
all right see it started off nice
I am I have a great [__] life thanks
to you guys coming out to my shows I
really appreciate everybody every single
person that bought a ticket this year
that gives me you know
the life that I have that I actually can
go out and hang out with my kids now
granted I didn't go out and buy a
Ferrari and be a [__] idiot either so
there's that you know thank God my dream
car was an f-250.
all right that's it dude the [__] Red
Sox like four or five games above 500
and we're still in last place I mean the
Yale East is no [__] joke we'll see
I'm excited I am excited
about baseball I like football too but I
am excited all right that's it go [__]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday